the Vatican reached a speedy decision
the accusations being leveled against
bishop t-box fun as are just too serious
among other things he's being criticized
for the spiraling costs of his new
residence which are putted more than 30
million euros now the Vatican has
suspended him from his duties pending an
investigation the code is the shouldn't
keep his office that's no way to manage
money money to get on this stock mr. sir
I don't think he can go back people are
just too angry such arrogance Rukia a
lot of people have formally left the
church people are disappointed and for
many it's the last straws and they're
leaving the Catholic Church councils
below Mahomet sweet off tickets of her
lesson has the bishop damaged the
reputation of the Catholic Church a
large majority say yes eighty-five
percent just eleven percent of Germans
disagree with that assessment it's bad
for the image of the Catholic Church
it's seen as ostentatious and wasteful
[ __ ] me off as a Catholic I hope this
will lead to more openness especially
when it comes to church finances versus
galavan mas manqué open the church does
a lot of good for example with carrot
ash and other charities we shouldn't
lose sight of that side of things
siouxsie & hintock one [ __ ] menangis
on the system as for Pope Francis the
scandal surrounding the Bishop of
Limburg is a serious issue all the more
so because the pontiff is placing
renewed emphasis on the virtues of
poverty and humility
you